paula slayer en direct donc d'israël
c'est notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur
ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir pour la merci d'être avec nous
justement cette troisième dose qui nous
intrigue en ce soir puisqu'elle concerne
les plus de 65 ans désormais les plus
fragiles peut-être bientôt toute la
population troisième dose donc
généraliser à tous depuis peu chez vous
en israël
comment les israéliens réagi style
justement ce nécessaire rappel
[Applaudissements]
le soutiennent ces troisièmes noces une
limite est important cependant le contre
cette vaccination mais elle évacue vite
l'idée du oui s'est joué lors
de l'impact à long terme de l'absinthe
ou tel sinistre elle se fend de
milliardaires est battue qui répondent
tous à vendre suggère qu'il ya quatre
autres représentants
discours scène rappelle mais n'ont pas
encore reçu
il ya beaucoup de discussions au mistral
discussion très intense sur la
vaccination des enfants se sont réunis
les gros titres actuels
les enfants ont tous inquiets aux gens
de venir recevoir un rappel des parents
sont contre sachez vous aimez à cause de
ma question générale je suis je pense
personnellement que cette vaccination
sera et
macédoniens sont des contaminations
étendu en israël le port du masque est
toujours de gatwick au montage et au
civil est toujours en
jeu parce qu'alger est toujours un rôti
paula ça veut dire qu en clair cet
effort qu'on demande aux populations est
ce qu'ils portent réellement ses fruits
on le voit il ya une situation favorable
sur le front sanitaire en israël
[Applaudissements]
tu dis que tu d'accord de celle là même
qui
nous rappelle sa troisième grossesse et
efficace à hauteur de 92% fin contre des
formes sérieuse de lakovic
à rapport à une personne qui va quelques
insultes de dos c'est bien sûr du matin
5h10 le vaccin déployées au monde
les experts rappellent cette présence a
permis à l'espagne de surmonter la
personne vague non ministère de la santé
en régie ce sera un nombre de cars
active que l'europe est vide en dessous
se signent un par jour et secondaire il
est pas moi est ce le nombre de
collectifs c'est par jour était de 10
millions la plupart des israéliens sont
ses racines que ce rappel ces trois
années après au pays de surmonter la
quatrième vague merci pour la slider
journée star fait internationale en
direct de tel à vivre